let's go to bethany from oklahoma
bethany from oklahoma you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can oh
perfect um i
i actually hopped on here not i'm not
even realizing
you were filming i was just hoping to
catch you i
don't know what time you all start the
show
so i happened to hop on and i got called
this is crazy um beautiful
i guess my question is um
in the past few days you've been talking
about how
biden is being um being criticized
for all of his executive orders yes and
we've talked about how you know he's
doing what people want him to do
um but the critique i'm seeing from
you know liberal friends is that since
we control
the house and the senate now why isn't
he going about it through legislation
because he doesn't
necessarily have to get republicans on
board
does he so a couple of thoughts usually
what you say
is yeah this is an important question so
there's a few different things
bethany first of all if the things joe
biden
uh uh if joe biden is dealing with
actual emergencies via
executive order then you have to do it
as quickly as possible
and so if if we agree some of these
things have to be changed
right away and i agree that some of the
things that
that biden did via executive order do
have to be changed right away
you do the executive order and then you
try to get a more permanent
legislative infrastructure in the next
two years during which joe biden will
have
um the control of the house and senate
so i that
that argument the idea that you don't
need to do any executive orders
because you have control and you can do
it all that that that's not a good
argument number one because if you have
an actual emergency you need to deal
with it as quickly as possible
number two not everything can be done
with a simple majority
uh there are things that that require 60
votes
in the senate in order to get done and
so it's not quite so simple now with
something like coveted relief
i'm ready for biden to stop the meetings
with republicans it was fine to do the
meeting
it was fine to listen to republicans who
want 600 billion instead of 1.9 trillion
but you can use budget reconciliation to
pass coveted relief with a simple
majority
and it's time to do it so i think that
any you know anytime you hear
such a general critique bethany like
biden doesn't need to do any executive
orders because he has the house and
senate and can just do everything
legislatively
it's such a general assessment that it
almost
certainly it falls short as an analysis
and that's exactly the case it's much
more complicated than that
gotcha yeah that makes sense and and i
had
forgotten that part about you know of
course things some things require more
than a simple majority that is
absolutely accurate and it takes time
and it takes time i mean
even even without republican obstruction
a lot of these things do have to go
through committee
and and you know i'm not defending the
the speed at which the covet stuff is
being done
i would have liked to see biden do the
meeting with republicans on january 22nd
and we could already be moving beyond it
but i understand
why he's giving them a meeting it now
it's just time to act and get it done
yeah and i i like what you said about um
you know
if it's true that they want to follow up
some of this stuff
with legislation um that does have a
longer
uh you know hold then that that makes
more sense too and that is what i will
um come back with when i hear that
talking point yeah i mean the critique
that in general
executive orders are a problem because
the next president can just undo it
that's always been a critique that's
that's not that's not uh different than
something that could be said
in the past it doesn't really change
whether for the time being that
executive orders can be done joe biden
is right or wrong to use them
gotcha well thank you yeah that's really
all i
i'm mainly just listening but i did have
that question that's been popping in my
head while i've
been watching your show um this week so
all right thanks bethany bethany from
oklahoma
great to hear from you and uh hope to
hear from you
again i want to take a second to tell
you about one of our sponsors s
h masks s h masks has everything you
need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear for
covid 19 and they're giving my audience
20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over 150 dollars you
can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david